buon pomeriggio e ringrazio gli
organizzatori di questo bellissimo
evento per l'opportunità che mi danno di
presentarvi un esempio pratico dire
silenzio di tipo socio ecologica che
stiamo portando avanti in lucania e che
sta attirando sempre più l'attenzione
dell'agenzia delle nazioni unite che si
occupa proprio di queste tematiche
in particolare della resilienza
applicata al processo di riduzione dei
rischi sia di natura naturale che di
natura antropica
ecco qua l'argomento principale di
questo modello ed è un'idea molto
semplice che abbiamo applicato in
lucania difficile da portare avanti ma
semplice pensare e decostruire la
resilienza attraverso una grande grande
network di tante piccole comunità per
capire l'importanza perché abbiamo
scelto questa strada bisogna un attimino
soffermarsi sul palcoscenico su cui
stiamo lavorando ed è la lucania
parliamo di un'area geografica che
comprende la basilicata ma non solo
il sud della campania il nord della
calabria è un'area di circa 200 piccole
e piccolissime comunità io vengo da un
paese di 500 abitanti capite non è un
paese mai ma tribunale volte la
definisco caratterizzate da che cosa da
un'identità culturale omogenea e anche
da una struttura socio economica molto
omogenea partire dall'intesa culturale
molto importante quando si parla di re
silenzio di resilienza sui territori
circa un milione di abitanti con tre
grandissimi rischi rischio sismico di
siti idrogeologico e rischio incendi
boschivi ma anche la regione comicamente
più depressa d'italia
con pochissime risorse finanziarie a
disposizione di un processo di
resilienza negli ultimi dieci anni
quest'area geografica è diventata da un
punto di vista strategico di sicurezza
nazionale forse l'area piu importante
dell'intero paese perché qui abbiamo la
massima concentrazione delle tre più
importanti risorse naturali necessarie
allo sviluppo di qualunque società
moderna energia il campo petrolifero
dell'europa continentale più ampio
pensate al momento stiamo parlando di
100.000 barili di petrolio al giorno
circa il 10 per cento del fabbisogno
nazionale
si parla di regime di 20 30 per cento
del fabbisogno nazionale ambiente tre
parti nazionali pollino appennino lucano
cilento collegati tra di loro
rappresentano il corridoio ecologico più
importante d'europa sia in termini di
dimensioni che di biodiversità e infine
l'ultima risorsa che voi qui in puglia
conoscete di cui puglia conoscete molto
bene l'importanza circa un miliardo di
metri cubi d'acqua in invasi artificiali
di fatto questa regione dipende in
maniera totale dall acqua che viene
dalla lucania
qual è il modello allora che abbiamo
voluto applicare è rappresentato dal
titolo di questa slide un modello bottom
up di resilienza cioè dal basso verso
l'alto e questo che sta attirando
l'attenzione delle nazioni unite da
questo punto di vista l'idea cominciavo
prima e costruire una grande rete di
piccole comunità in una realtà socio
economica di quel tipo
per noi era stato fondamentale mettere
assieme in rete i tre mattoni principali
di un processo di resilienza e quando si
parla di resilienza si deve parlare del
territorio e quindi di un processo che
parta dal basso
il senso di solidarietà
attraverso le forme di volontariato che
rappresentano poi capitale umano di
grande quantità messo a disposizione del
territorio della comunità
la comunità stessa e le istituzioni
locali per fare che cosa che serve la
rete nella resilienza serve a costruire
la massa critica senza della quale non
si può operare intervenire rispetto ai
grandi eventi emergenziali le grandi
crisi che possono colpire le comunità e
inoltre soprattutto serve a costruire
coesione sociale nelle comunità il primo
protagonista volontariato
parliamo della associazione di
volontariato gruppo lucano che in questo
momento ai 5.000 volontari presenti in
105 comuni lucani con strutture
operative di grandissime dimensioni di
respiro nazionale per gestire le grandi
crisi e con strutture specializzate
anche per gestire qualunque tipo di
evento
diciamo di resilienza e di crisi che
possa presentarsi sul territorio ma
l'intervento è a tutto tondo la
resilienza non si fa soltanto
intervenendo e ricostruendo ma si fa
soprattutto prevenendo diciamo l'urto o
prevenendo gli effetti di un urto sulla
comunità
ecco per cui diciamo avere strutture di
previsione prevenzione è fondamentale
parliamo nell'associazione di
volontariato che gestisce una divisione
scientifica con volontari provenienti
dai centri di ricerca delle università
dagli ordini professionali che
gestiscono reti di monitoraggio di tutti
i tipi inclusi impose per l'antincendio
reti di tipo satellitare parliamo poi di
una divisione che si occupa della
diffusione della cultura di resilienza e
della riduzione del rischio tra la gente
è il pezzo più importante e non finale
di un processo di re silenzio della
comunità
giusto per dare un'idea negli ultimi
anni vi parliamo di circa 2300 volontari
e operatori emergenziali che hanno
vissuto formazione medio alta
parliamo in una regione molto piccola di
interventi fatti in 43 comuni su 14.000
studenti proprio per portare avanti un
processo di educazione all
a queste problematiche ecco qua 1993 a
viggiano 20 persone si mettono assieme
per creare un primo nucleo di
volontariato di protezione civile
ecco la rete che si espande ecco dove
siamo oggi capite da questa immagine
quando si parla di resilienza
l'importanza di una rete in qualunque
punto nodo di quella rete succeda un
evento un trauma un problema
immediatamente alla rete attiva a cerchi
concentrici sempre più ampi le strutture
intorno a quel punto fino a raggiungere
la massa critica necessaria a sostenere
ea intervenire su quella problematica
secondo protagonista in un processo di
resilienza del territorio diciamo le
istituzioni locali e la rete di
istituzioni locali non basta una rete di
cittadini di cittadinanza attiva il
diventa importante e fondamentale una
rete di istituzioni locali nel 2011 a
ginevra si è tenuta una conferenza
mondiale sulle tematiche di resilienza
alla riduzione del rischio promossa
proprio dall agenzia che si occupa di
queste tematiche
in quell'occasione volontari e
istituzioni regionali della basilicata
hanno partecipato alla conferenza si
sono incontrate vedete l'immagine a
sinistra con la responsabile europea
del programma di resilienza delle
nazioni unite e hanno sono entrati in
contatto con questa campagna mex making
cities resilient trendy la tua città
resiliente una campagna che da alcuni
anni le nazioni unite stanno portando
avanti e che era interessante per noi
perché metteva in evidenza con proprio
come un organismo internazionale di
quella portata avesse scelto il discorso
di il ruolo dell'istituzione locale come
punto cardine fondamentale per portare
avanti un processo di resilienza mi
territori nelle comunità siamo tornati a
casa
abbiamo attivato la rete questo è un
esempio del vantaggio di una rete 2012
24 comuni lucani entrano a far parte
della campagna mondiale delle nazioni
unite su undici comuni in tutta italia
nel 2015
arriviamo a 109 comuni italiani che ora
fanno parte lucani chiedo scusa che ora
fanno parte di questa campagna rispetto
a confronto soltanto quindici comuni non
lucani ma diciamo questa campagna cosa
serviva serviva a cominciare a costruire
il primo livello di rete istituzionale
il livello in cui di sharing
dell'informazione di sharing
dell'esperienza di sensibilizzazione
delle istituzioni stesse
ma per noi non bastava per parlare di
resilienza e bisogna cominciare a
pensare anche a soluzioni innovative
specifiche del territorio su cui si
opera
ecco perché
abbiamo cominciato a lavorare in stretto
contatto con il comune di viggiano
abbiamo continuato alla collaborazione
stretta con le nazioni unite nel 2015 a
marzo di quest'anno abbiamo partecipato
alla terza conferenza mondiale tenuta
sendai in giappone la conferenza nel
quale sono state stabilite le politiche
mondiali di resilienza delle nazioni
unite per i prossimi 15 anni
così avvenuta in quell'occasione la
città di viggiano ha ricevuto il
riconoscimento di città modello di
resilienza e il quarantasettesimo comune
a livello mondiale a ricevere questo
riconoscimento
ma quello che per noi era importante era
capire perché
viceversa e questo riconoscimento è la
motivazione e per aver portato avanti un
approccio innovativo di tipo bottom up
alla resilienza basato su tre cardini
fondamentali il cardine finanziario
budget soldi assegnati alla creazione di
strutture di resilienza il sostegno alle
forme di cittadinanza attiva e quindi la
capacità di far crescere la
partecipazione di mettere in rete questa
partecipazione e veniva menzionata
esplicitamente il ruolo giocato dal
gruppo lucano è infine la creazione di
strumenti innovativi nuovi per sostenere
la resilienza in realtà di tanti di
piccole comunità come quella lucana in
particolare
dar via a una fondazione di comunità che
si occupi tra le altre cose in maniera
diretta e specifica di resilienza sul
territorio quali sono stati gli impegni
che il comune di viggiano appreso
ufficialmente in occasione dell'incontro
di sendai
in primo luogo approfondire la
conoscenza dello stato di resilienza del
suo territorio ma non come atto interno
ma attraverso una peer review di esperti
nominati dalle nazioni unite che entro
il 2016 analizzeranno le caratteristiche
del territorio del comune e
individueranno i punti di debolezza i
punti di forza e daranno suggerimenti su
cosa fare che fare per migliorare le
condizioni di resilienza della comunità
secondo punto impegno è quello di
diffondere il concetto della resilienza
i punti cardine della rete in silenzio
livello nazionale internazionale
attraverso scambi con altre città altre
comunità
al momento il comune sta completando un
processo di gemellaggio con la città di
minsk in bielorussia su due tematiche
importanti per noi
uno è il tipo di incidenti chiamato nate
sono incidenti di natura tecnologica che
fanno seguito a incidenti naturali
giusto per farvi capire il concetto
l'incidente di fukushima causato dallo
tsunami è un incidente classico di tipo
nate questa matematica simile che vive
labiale mila cittadini scala della
russia che vive la città di viggiano
rispetto alle problematiche
dell'estrazione petrolifera
il rischio sismico l'altra tematica e
diffusione della cultura tra i giovani
della cultura di resilienza tra i
giovani e poche parole ore sullo
strumento che io noi consideriamo il più
innovativo in questo processo quello di
creare una fondazione di comunità che si
dedichi a queste tematiche e che
soprattutto mette a disposizione
strumenti innovativi e finanziari nuovi
per affrontare il problema della
resilienza cos'è la fondazione mallett è
una fondazione onlus che ha come
obiettivo lo sviluppo umano sostenibile
delle comunità lucane
ci tengo molto a mettere l'accento sul
termine umano si parla molto troppo di
sviluppo sostenibile e non si introduce
la componente fondamentale che è quella
della componente umana cosa significa il
parametro del benessere e della qualità
della vita dell'individuo alla comunità
deve essere fondamentale nella
valutazione di uno sviluppo di una
comunità stessa quali sono gli strumenti
su cui noi vogliamo operare
trattandosi di piccole comunità capite
bene non parliamo di grandi strumenti
finanziari
vogliamo attivare tutta una serie di
strumenti finanziari dedicati alle
piccole realtà come per esempio il
microcredito il patient capital il
social di
social social business crowd funding
crowdsourcing qual è l'idea interessante
che piace molto alle nazioni unite su
questo cioè far diventare la resilienza
anche un'opportunità economica del
territorio non semplicemente una spesa
un qualcuna un qualcosa in più un peso
per il territorio ma farlo diventare
opportunità economica ma per fare questo
bisogna che chi lavora in resilienza
abbia l'intelligenza di introd
introdurre elementi innovativi
tecnologie e modelli metodologie
innovative che possono poi essere
esportate al di fuori e quindi possono
diventare in altre aree in altri
territori con caratteristiche simili e
quindi possono diventare opportunità
economica per gli operatori di
resilienza del territorio da cui questo
processo nasce è un'associazione una
comunità che una fondazione che parte
dal basso anche questa 180 associazioni
e cooperative con circa 10 mila
associati presenti i 90 di 131 comuni
della basilicata e parliamo poi di una
componente molto vasta di stakeholders
del territorio e questa è la mia
confusione mi avvia alla conclusione
quali sono state le buone pratiche che
noi abbiamo messi in atto per riuscire a
portare avanti un processo di tipo
bottom up di resilienza in promuovo
conquistare la fiducia nelle nostre
piccole comunità
se non si costruisce le crea fiducia e
se non si riesce a mettere insieme
attraverso il processo la fiducia i vari
componenti sociali del territorio
diventa difficile fare qualcosa l'altro
l'altro strumento è individuare i
bisogni e trovare delle soluzioni
pratiche immediate da dare a questi
bisogni terzo utilizzare il meccanismo
della rete per costruire la massa
critica
altrimenti non si fa resilienza quando
si ad alto livello
la massa critica è fondamentale per
affrontare problemi e dimensioni quali
quelli che si possono
pare di fronte a rischi naturali o
rischi antropici e infine creare una
visione per il futuro e soprattutto
ricostruire quel tessuto di coesione
sociale delle piccole comunità senza del
quale non c'è sviluppo né umano né
sostenibile ma nemmeno sviluppo grazie